This is Vladivostok, the largest
Russian city on the Pacific Ocean.
Vladivostok is home to a number
of unique attractions, including:
- One of the country’s only two funiculars,
commissioned as part of a 1959 plan
to build “Soviet San Francisco”,
- Impressive bridges built
for the 2012 APEC summit,
- And one of the world’s largest aquariums.
But perhaps its most unusual attraction is
something you won’t find listed on
any travel guide: “Repair Korea”,
an exclusively-North Korean contractor
specializing in home repair and renovation.
Its website, translated here to
English, acknowledges your skepticism,
“Some people think you shouldn't invite
Koreans to repair your apartment”,
but reassures you that, quote, “Unlike
spoiled Russian specialists… Koreans work
extremely professionally, accurately and in
full compliance with world quality standards”.
But don’t assume North Korean builders are
confined to any one construction niche.
Others helped build the World Cup stadium in St.
Petersburg and apartment buildings in Moscow.
Neither do they work only in Russia. After the
U.S. State Department commended the country
of Kuwait for cutting ties with North
Korea, Kuwait responded with confusion,
saying “There are no plans to expel North
Korean laborers and Kuwait has never done so”.
The regime collects the vast
majority of these wages,
while recipient nations get access
to cheap, hard-working labor.
This trade is often cited as
proof that sanctions don’t
work — it seems there’s always a way around them.
After the UN demanded that countries expel
North Korean workers in 2017, for instance,
Russia simply re-issued them
“tourist” and “student” visas.
The country is also responsible
for countless hacking campaigns,
ransomware attacks, the production of
counterfeits, and a dozen other illicit odd jobs.
But, in fact, the opposite.
The extreme lengths it goes to evade sanctions,
even when the payoff is relatively small,
suggests they do have a powerful effect.
And yet there hasn’t been any meaningful
diplomatic progress in decades.
So, why do sanctions bring Iran to the
negotiating table, but not North Korea?
Sponsored by CuriosityStream
and Nebula — get both and watch
the bonus video that accompanies
this one for just 15 bucks a year.
North Korea has sought nuclear weapons,
with varying degrees of urgency,
for its entire existence.
In 1959, just six years after
the end of the Korean War,
the Soviet Union agreed to build it a
reactor — though not without conditions.
The Soviets pressured them to
sign the Non-Proliferation Treaty,
which they finally did in 1985.
But inconsistencies emerged almost immediately.
After signing the treaty, countries are
required to submit an “initial report”,
in which they declare how much nuclear
material is already in their possession.
North Korea waited seven years to do
so, and international inspectors soon
noticed a discrepancy in the
amount of declared plutonium.
It then refused to allow further
inspections, withdrew from the treaty,
and even neglected its binding commitments.
But this was only the first of
many broken promises to come.
In 1994, after 4-months of negotiations, the
U.S. agreed to give it two light water reactors
and 500,000 tons of fuel oil, annually, in
exchange for the freezing of its weapons program.
Then North Korea was caught
secretly enriching uranium,
and, according to the U.S., even admitted to it.
A new round of negotiations began in 2003,
which appeared to reach a breakthrough.
Nuclear facilities were dismantled and
the country was removed from America’s
list of “State Sponsors of Terrorism”.
Predictably, North Korea announced it would
restart its nuclear program several years later.
At this point, no doubt remained about
its true intentions — dishonesty had
been demonstrated time and time and time again.
Perhaps even more worrisome was its long
history of sporadic and dangerous behavior.
This includes multiple attempted assassinations
of the South Korean president, airplane bombs,
the 1968 capture of an American ship, and
firing at both military and civilian planes.
And when the carrot fails, conventional
wisdom would suggest it’s time for the
stick. Sanctions were the only option left, it
seemed, for a country that couldn’t be trusted.
Over time, they expanded from covering
military equipment to travel, luxury goods,
raw materials, and even food — severely
restricting even basic humanitarian aid.
But just as negotiation appeared
less and less effective over time,
sanctions have now been around long enough
to identify a pattern: They don’t work.
The problem is not, contrary to popular
thinking, that sanctions are easily evaded.
In 2017 and 18, a decline in
trade led to a 3.5 and 4.1%
decrease in its GDP. Exports
declined by 90% in 2018.
Of course, neither are they perfectly effective.
Far from it. There will always be black markets
and someone else with a vested interest
in North Korea’s continued existence.
China, for instance, supplies its
neighbor with just enough coal, oil,
and food to prevent its collapse, the vacuum of
which would soon be filled by an American ally.
This measly income is akin to an unemployed
person recycling bottles and cans — it’s not
nothing, but pretty close
at the scale of a nation.
To put things in perspective, North
Korea’s GDP is half that of Vermont’s,
the U.S. state with the smallest economy,
yet its population is forty times larger.
The problem is that sanctions
don’t work as intended.
They clearly haven’t ended its nuclear
program or put an end to missile tests.
The first reason is that the
wrong people are affected.
The only group whose suffering
might induce change are elites,
yet the burden of sanctions is mostly
felt by the middle class and below.
As inflation increases, average,
working-class households struggle
to maintain the same standard of living.
High, sanctions-driven prices mean that 97%
of Afghanistan will fall below the poverty
line this year, according to a UN estimate.
When the rich and powerful are affected, they can
simply cut back on social programs to compensate.
Now, you might argue this is how things are
supposed to work. The civilian population
puts pressure on the government and the threat
of losing power encourages it to change course.
But this effect is strongest in democracies,
which sanctioned countries are less likely to be.
North Korea, on the other hand, goes well
beyond “less democratic” — it’s the textbook
example of a country unlikely to
experience political revolution.
Insulated from the rest of the world
in virtually every respect, it can
easily control the narrative — blaming higher
prices and lower quality of life on the enemy.
If anything, sanctions have the opposite effect.
Just as residents of Yugoslavia blamed the UN,
not their own government, in the 90s, they
instill a unifying patriotism among North Koreans.
Again, the net effect of sanctions for its
leaders is unquestionably negative. They lead
to malnutrition, death, disease, population
decline, and, ultimately, economic failure.
After the collapse of the Soviet
Union, the regime’s closest ally,
between 600,000 and one
million Koreans died of hunger.
While sanctions were not the direct
cause, they certainly didn’t help.
Even if you believe these deaths mean nothing to
Kim Jong-un, the “axis of evil” label diminishes
the country’s legitimacy. It desperately
wants to be treated like a “normal” country.
This is evidenced, according to many experts,
by the continuous cycle of missile tests,
which are followed by demands for
negotiation. Despite having long ago
demonstrated its nuclear capabilities, it’s
nevertheless discontent with the status quo.
So, we’re seemingly back to square one.
If it wants sanctions lifted,
why doesn’t it strike a deal?
To answer this question, try
putting yourself, no matter how
unnatural it may feel, in the shoes of Kim
Jong-un, whose #1 fear is regime change.
This deeply-held fear is not Stalinist paranoia
or an archaic leftover of the Soviet era.
Kim Jong-un has every legitimate reason to
worry. After all, none of this is theoretical.
Libya acceded to U.S. demands, halting the
development of its nuclear program, in 2003.
Eight years later, the dead body of
Moammar Gadhafi was on public display.
Just in case the lesson that an autocrat should
never surrender his weapons of mass destruction
wasn’t made clear enough, American
officials have since made repeated,
unequivocal threats that the same
thing could happen to Kim Jong-un.
In the lead-up to the 2018 Singapore Summit,
for instance, President Trump warned that
his North Korean counterpart would suffer the
same fate as Gadhafi if a deal wasn’t reached.
U.S., South Korean, and Japanese forces regularly
conduct mock decapitation drills on its doorstep.
And in 2006, former Secretary of
Defense William Perry published an
op-ed titled “If Necessary, Strike and Destroy”.
None of this, obviously, absolves
North Korea of any responsibility.
Its negotiating behavior has ranged from merely
skittish to downright deceitful. But, in truth,
the U.S. has also given it plenty
of genuine reason for skepticism.
What the simplistic version of events — suggesting
North Korea never intended on following-through
on its promises — from earlier misses is
the lack of American political continuity.
The 1994 “Agreed Framework”, when North
Korea was caught secretly enriching uranium,
for example, is remembered as a failure.
While its actions certainly violated the
spirit of the agreement, it did suspend
production of plutonium, as promised, which
was a significant step in the right direction.
Also missing is that the Clinton
administration completed a review
of U.S. policy on September 15th, 1999,
recommending, quote, “a new, comprehensive
and integrated approach to…negotiations”.
But that radical, new approach
never came to fruition,
because George Bush won the
presidency 14 months later.
Bush began his own policy
review, which took another year
and ended by effectively
suspending the Agreed Framework.
Now, the U.S. had every right to
withdraw from its side of the agreement.
After all, North Korea had clearly
violated it first. But, in doing so,
it let North Korea off the hook for everything,
allowing it to resume the production of plutonium.
Not only did America wilfully lose the
little bit of progress it had made,
it also permanently diminished the
very currency of negotiations: trust.
Again, blame lies squarely in North Korea’s court,
but one can easily see America’s actions would
inspire less than supreme confidence in Pyongyang.
In addition to the lack of political
continuity which leads countries around
the world to doubt America’s long-term
commitments and think they can simply
“wait it out” for a new administration,
there’s also the issue of funding.
Presidents can negotiate, but
only Congress controls the purse.
When the two branches disagree, commitments
made by the president may be broken. The
other country won’t care whose exact fault
it is — only that the promise was broken.
Another neglected aspect of the Agreed Framework
were the delays. Angry that the U.S. was quote
“rewarding” the enemy with fuel oil and two Light
Water Reactors — which cannot be used to build
nuclear weapons — Congress withheld funding,
which led North Korea to doubt its sincerity.
A lot has changed in the last thirty-some years.
Aside from a few brief pauses here and there,
North Korea has continued improving its
capabilities — from possessing “one or two bombs”,
to missile-delivery, hydrogen bombs,
ballistic missiles, and, most recently,
long-range, road-mobile ballistic missiles
capable of reaching anywhere on the U.S. mainland.
And yet the U.S. still demands the exact same
thing it did in 1990: “complete, verifiable, and
irreversible denuclearization”. Its bottom-line is
that North Korea abandon 30-years of development,
economic sacrifices, and, likely, the
only thing keeping Kim Jong-un alive.
If this was ever a realistic demand,
it stopped being one decades ago.
Each successive American president
arrives fresh in the White House believing
they can be “the one” to finally
resolve the crisis once and for all.
But they soon discover that there
are only two possible pathways:
Either be forever known as “the
one” to accept that it’s too late,
that North Korea is and will remain a nuclear
power, that there’s nothing the U.S. can do
about it, and risk being perceived as
“soft” on the enemy of all enemies,
Or accept nothing less than the only
thing Kim Jong-un won’t ever agree to:
complete denuclearization, setting themselves
up to fail from the very beginning.
If the goal is merely to punish, the United
States has, unquestionably, succeeded. But,
more likely, having an effect has
been confused with effectiveness.
The irony is that, by refusing
to accept even 1% risk,
America must now accept much more than 1% risk.
The world’s most powerful country cannot
cope with the fact that the one country
beyond its control has an economy
the size of Mozambique and a leader
whose most discernible personality
trait is a passion for Swiss cheese.
So accustomed to having the final say, the
ability to kill any leader of any country
at any time, the U.S. is almost perfectly
ill-suited to deal with a country where such
threats are exactly the cause of angst, and
therefore, bad behavior, in the first place.
So, what’s the solution? And
is North Korea an exception,
or are economic sanctions vastly overrated?
Both these questions are the subject of
the bonus video that accompanies this one on
Nebula, the creator-owned streaming platform.
By signing up for Nebula, you get access
to a dozen other PolyMatter bonus videos
and extended content, exclusive Originals,
and, for the same low price, CuriositySteam.
CuriosityStream is home to great documentaries
on history, science, and technology. Another
country that’s struggled under the weight of U.S.
sanctions is Cuba — but the lack of tourists has
turned its natural environment into an untouched
experiment. This documentary explores that
dilemma: Can Cuba keep its beaches pristine, or
will it eventually succumb to financial pressure?
Click the link on screen right now to
get both Nebula and CuriosityStream
for just fifteen bucks a year and go
watch the bonus video over on Nebula.